فرز 51% فاصل ثلاثه اذا تخطينا الان بحسب
اخر تحديث لهذه النتائج الاوليه تخطينا
فرز
51% من اصوات الناخبين الرئيس الحالي رجب
طيب اردوغان ما زال متقدما مع
52.3% مقابل
42.11% لمرشح تحالف الشعب المعارض كمال
كريشتار اوغلو تحديدا تم فرز
51.8% من اصوات الناخبين بحسب هذه النتائج
الاوليه كمال كاليستار اوغلو
42.11% مقابل 52% مقابل
وثلاثه بالمئه والسينان اوغان يبقى عند
حاجز الخمسه بالمئه فاصل 33 اذا هذا اخر
تحديث ايضا هناك تحديث اخر فيما يتعلق
بالمقاعد البرلمانيه مع فرز اكثر من 26%
من صناديق الاقتراع تحالف الجمهور حاصل
حتى الان على
56.9 عشره بالمئه مقابل
30.5 لتحالف الشعب المعارض واعود واذكر
مره جديده بان هذه هي الارقام والنتائج
الاوليه التي تصلنا والتي تعلن حتى الان
تقدم مرشح الجمهور رجب طيب اردوغان ب
52.3% مقابل
42.11 بالمئه لمرشح الشعب المعارض كمال
كيتشتار اوغل